welcome to another Dr saddler's honest
book reviews where I give you
unvarnished and critical but hopefully
judicious reads on Works in philosophy
RIT large which includes ethics applied
ethics leadership self heel personal
development and a lot of other stuff the
book that we're looking at today br
with senica a stoic Guide to the Art of
Living by David fedel a colleague and
I'd like to think of as a friend uh fits
very very solidly into the purview of
the series because it is indeed about
stoicism about senica one of the great
stoic philosophers and about what we can
learn about how to live a better life so
a lot to say about about this work we'll
Jump Right
In we'll begin this review by looking at
the three s's the style of the work the
structure and kind of a summary of what
is going on what you can expect if you
get your hands on this uh particular
book so the style Fiddler is a great
writer in terms of literary style this
is an eminently readable work it's very
well organized I would say too so it's
not just uh well written and you know
well thought out in how the different
sections and paragraphs come together
but but it's it's a work that actually
is a totality and so it's quite
admirable in that respect um the
structure of the work is you know sort
of what you might expect it's a book
that begins with a preface that we're
going to look at in just a moment and
then you know after a short introduction
where we get to learn about senica a bit
and why the book is focused on him we
have a whole bunch of chapters which are
all topically oriented you could say and
I'm going to read through the listing
now I do want to point out that the
chapter headings might not give you a
complete IDE idea of what is going to be
discussed in that chapter but that's
often the case with works like this so
the Lost Art of friendship is the first
chapter uh second one value your time
don't postpone living Third how to
overcome worry and anxiety fourth the
problem with anger fifth wherever you go
there you are you can't escape yourself
fifth how to tame adversity so so far
with you know lots of emotion stuff life
events and then um seven is an
interesting one why you should never
complain that will probably be a bit
controversial uh eight the battle
against Fortune how to survive poverty
and extreme wealth important because
Sena himself was extremely wealthy nine
vicious crowds and the ties That Bind
looking at our social nature 10 how to
be authentic and contribute to society
11 living fully regardless of death and
that also looks at old age um 12 give
grief its due 13 love and gratitude and
then finally finishing up with chapter
14 Freedom tranquility and Lasting Joy
which is you could say the the goal the
end of stoic philosophy and then we have
a number of other things as well as you
could you know imagine there's a big
bibliography and an index and some uh
further reading senica's philosophical
writings and there's a number of
endnotes as well but I think that what's
kind of nice about this so there is a uh
fairly short acknowledgments page
towards the end and then we have this
appendix stoic philosophical exercises
and it's just a few lines about each of
these but I think that can be quite
useful for some readers um as a matter
of fact in the acknowledgments we learn
something uh that uh Fiddler brought up
early on he calls these fresh
translations and so he says the stoic
philosophical quotations in this book
were newly translated by me working in
collaboration with Elizabeth Mercier a
Latin and Greek professor at Purdue
University um we hope that you will
enjoy these fresh translations of senica
and that the access they provide to his
still living ideas and arguments so that
that's quite nice to to find out right
um there's also going to be a number of
illustrations and diagrams in the book I
should mention and what is he doing each
of the chapters I mentioned is delving
into a really important topic an idea an
issue that stoic philosophy and
specifically senica's stoic philosophy
is going to help us out with so what you
get in each of the chapters is fidar
saying okay here's a a life issue that
we need to face here's what senica has
to contribute here's why it's actually
helpful for us here's where you might
think that he's wrong but perhaps uh he
isn't wrong about this sort of thing it
also uh the book as a whole provides
kind of a overall summary of senica's
life and that of his uh correspondence
as well and it gets into some other
philosophers here there mentions a bit
about Cicero a bit about Aristotle a bit
about others as well um it's not
exclusively Sena Focus there are a
number of other quotes and discussions
of other key stoic authors interestingly
at the beginning Fiddler is going to say
well these are epicus and Marcus
Aurelius but we're also going to see
Heracles brought up as well as some
others and I should mention that we're
going to get some discussions of other
uh philosophers or theorist thinkers so
we'll get you know some discussion of n
in the amorfa section there's a number
of references to Tim Ferris to to other
um you know
researchers self-help uh productivity
advisors and uh we leave even see a
discussion in there about Albert Ellis
and rational emotive behavior therapy
which is you know coming from uh to some
degree stoos ISM more epicus than senica
of course but certainly relevant so
those are the three s is the summary of
what's going on in this book it's
designed to help you understand senica
maybe incorporate some of his insights
into your own life the style and the
overall structure of the
work
so what are the key ideas that this book
is going to get across to you I think we
can start very early on uh in this a
life truly worth living section where
fatal brings up eight core teachings of
Roman stoicism this is you know I think
a useful overview I'm just going to run
through these it'll give you some idea
of where he's coming from first is live
in agreement with nature to find
happiness the second virtue or
Excellence of one's inner character is
the only true good third some things are
up to us or entirely under control other
things are not fourth while we can't
control what happens to us in the
external world we can control our inner
judgments and how we respond to Life's
events fifth when something negative
happens or we're struck by adversity we
shouldn't be surprised by it but see it
as an opportunity to create a better
situation six uh virtue or possessing an
excellent character as its own reward
but it also results in udonia or
happiness this is a state of mental
tranquility and inner Joy seven real
philosophy involves making progress this
is going to be a very important topic
eight it's essential that we as
individuals should contribute to society
and you know is that everything the book
is about no but that covers a lot of
ground uh what is going to be discussed
I think it's quite interesting also in
this uh section that we're going to get
this very interesting assertion which is
actually a chap or topic sub chapter
heading senica's world is our world and
fider says if you read senica's writings
one of the most striking things you'll
notice is how he seems to be precisely
describing our present day world even
though he is right 2,000 years ago now
obviously we're not living in the Roman
Empire you know in uh pre-industrial
technology or anything like that
but I actually think he's quite right
about this and you know that's part of
why we go back to ancient philosophy
it's so relevant he he says a little bit
later on what makes Sena unique in the
stoic tradition was his deep
psychological insight into The Human
Condition including human ambition and
fears he was the first person in the
western world who deeply explored the
psychology of consumerism right so quite
interesting there um going
on there's a a good discussion in here
about something that we could
call using their old Parliament a stoic
Paradox the notion that virtue and vice
moral goodness and moral Badness is like
an onoff switch you're either virtuous
or you're vicious that's the stoic
official line you could say and senak
himself will Embrace that at certain
points and also deviate that from that
at certain points as well and this is
connected with the idea of the stoic
sage and one of the problems that comes
up with this well if that's the case
then how do we actually make any
progress away from being vicious towards
being virtuous because none of us are
the sage right so this is uh quite
important and like he's going to say in
my view Zeno's notion of an extreme
dichotomy between a sage and the rest of
humanity was not a helpful idea while
certainly attention getting it was
harmful to the stoic school school and
it brought quite a bit of ridicule on
the stoics from other ancient
philosophers plist like you know
Plutarch for example aristotelians like
Alexander of aphrodisius and and others
as well um I I think that's that's uh
quite right and it's an important matter
to uh delve into and to
discuss um there's a a lot of attention
being given to the way emotions work and
there's even you know an entire chapter
for example on the problem with anger
understandable since senica wrote an
entire book on anger and uh what we find
here here is a good discussion of the uh
feelings or protop
passions uh and other emotions negative
and positive that then we feel and you
know feter you could say is trying to
make the same points that senica himself
is um there's a a nice discussion a
little bit later on about well what is
virtue this is a term that we use a lot
in uh not just virtue ethics but ethics
more broadly but a lot of people are
quite confused about what this means and
so he gives you kind of an overview not
just of how the stoics understood it but
going all the way back to to Plato and
uh connecting it up with what is
actually up to us and what isn't up to
us he says that in stoic philosophy
these two ideas that virtue is the only
true good and some things are outside
our control are like two powerful
chemical substances when they are
combined and mixed together and intense
reaction occurs and an entirely new way
of viewing the world comes into being so
that's that's uh quite good as well uh
we get an interesting discussion about
um the stoic idea of following nature
and looking at nature as being something
rational this is actually in the section
on why you should not complain um so the
stoics thought that nature was actually
governed by infused with this
rationality a
logos um that we can tap into and
understand and he says because we're
rational creatures we're born with the
task of trying to understand the the
world nature as a whole along with our
own human natures and the relationships
that exist between the greater world and
our inner selves we're born to develop
our rational capacities right he says
there's nothing unscientific about the
stoic belief in logos and there's
nothing irrational about the stoic
belief in fate either but he says where
Modern readers end up having trouble uh
and some Modern stoics is with
Providence or
pronoia um and he says you know it has
nothing to do with the Christian idea of
Providence certainly anti dates it right
I mean it to say it has nothing to do
with it maybe a little bit too strong of
an idea Christians and stoics were
certainly engaged with each other for a
number of
centuries uh before stoicism disappears
as an independent
philosophy um so you know this is uh uh
quite a good discussion of that as well
um there's an interesting what as we
move to the social aspects an
interesting um assertion that fidd is
going to make which I quite like saying
that um tribalism is really one of our
greatest enemies right um and so you
know I think that that is quite accurate
when it comes to the stoics um he also
asserts that
um uh natur law and thereby in some
respect natural rights have their origin
in stoic philosophy or at least stoic
ideas through Enlightenment thinkers
that then are going to be bringing these
matters up and there is a discussion as
well towards the end about uh the value
of consistency you know Sonica has a
work on constancy and maybe this is
something that doesn't get quite enough
stress in the contemporary literature
about stoicism that it's very important
to have
consistency in one's practice without
like assuming that one is going to get
it right every single time
the over and over again doing things
seeing whether they jive with each other
whether they
map on to each other or whether there's
as epicus would put it contradictions or
conflicts Mah in Greek right so those
are all uh some key ideas I will say as
well we mentioned practices a little bit
earlier you're going to find a lot of
practices uh that other stoic uh authors
do discuss throughout this book peppered
in when it's um opopo when it's useful
when it makes sense so it's not as if
fider is starting out saying okay here's
your 15 or 30 stoic practices he instead
he's going to be like okay here's where
a more Fati could be useful here's where
um you know um thinking about bad things
that are going to to happen Prim meditat
malorum it could be useful here's what
it looks like right so those are some of
the key features of the book as
well there are a number of good features
about this book that I can praise and
call your attention to I'm always happy
to do so um I'm going to begin by saying
that as a overall work I think that this
would be a great
introduction to senica and you know I'll
I'll put it to you this way as somebody
who's been studying senica for years and
even teaching him in classes there's a
few things here where I was like like oh
yeah that's that that makes a lot of
sense this is actually a great way for
me to look at it thanks David for uh
putting that in front of me so I've
learned some things myself in the
process of reading this I think for
somebody who has no background or just
you know knows that Sonica was somebody
important you would get a lot of good
stuff in this um about what senica
actually teaches
has to offer you and the way that
Fiddler talks about sen I think perhaps
because there's so much
personal you know background woven into
this fider himself he calls it breakfast
with senica because he reads senica at
breakfast and he does so because he
found that senica was actually helpful
for him in understanding and living and
responding to challenges in his own life
right so he can he can lead you along
quite well uh fidler is a great guide to
another great guide
Sonica and I think that um it could be
like a great threshold you walk across
it and now you're ready to to read
senica and so it could be kind of a
companion piece to actually reading
senica's letters or on anger or on
constancy or uh on the shortness of life
or on benefits or many of the other
works that fidar is going to talk about
uh
there's something else that I I think I
particularly like about this book and
that's liking something about um
Fiddler's presentation of Sena so you
know philosophers typically will use
examples analogies and metaphors to get
things across particularly when they are
as Sonica is writing to other people
whether it's in letters or whether it's
you know writing a book to them as a
guide book for something and senica does
use a lot of all of these examples
analogies metaphors Fiddler is good with
bringing those up and not just saying
well here's senica's idea and then
leaving it there he explains it he
unpacks it a bit he tries to make it
relevant to our own time and FID also
brings up his own contemporary metaphors
and examples and I I think that's quite
helpful and valuable per you know
especially for a beginner reader who
might be like what in the hell is being
talked about here so that that's
important um I also think
that Fiddler has made a deliberate
choice we mentioned that this is these
are new translations Fiddler has made a
deliberate choice to take some of the
stoic
terminology that that even back when
they coined it people are like what in
the hell are you talking about what does
this term mean and to try to make it a
bit more relatable a bit more
contemporary for us so one prime example
of this instead of talking about
preferred
indifference right Fiddler is going to
say listen things like wealth or health
or good looks those are not Goods as
such but they are advantageous is now
this isn't completely new right other
people have translated things that way
but I think that stressing that is quite
important or talking about feelings as
opposed to protop passions this very
technical term feelings and emotions
making a a contrast between them now of
course you know you can never make
everything perfectly clear to everybody
because language is ambiguous but uh I
think this actually is doing the reader
some some benefit you know some
conferring on them some Advantage if we
want to use the very
terminology um each of the chapter I
would say gives you
enough to understand what senica's point
of view is what the stoic point of view
is and to start putting some of this
stuff into practice in your own life so
they're not super long um much more
could be said about any of the topics
that fidler is exploring here but I
think that and this is tough to do as a
writer this is one of the good points of
this work you know knowing when to say
all right that is a sufficient amount
they can go and and check out senica if
they want to get more you know knowing
how to not overwhelm people with things
that's that's quite good um there's two
other things that are towards the end of
the book that I particularly like and so
I'm going to call your attention to so
uh senica is one of the stoics who does
in fact go against the stoic let's Again
official uh line about stuff when it
comes to grief uh you know he writes
some letters of consolation he's got
some letters uh in the moral letters
about this and here's f
description senica's basic approach to
grief is that we should give grief it's
due in other words we should allow our
natural tears to flow freely but never
force them and never make our grief
appear to be more intense just because
we are in the presence of others um and
you know we can make distinctions
between different kinds of tears that he
talks about here tears of shock uh tears
of of Joy tears of sadness um and you
know these are all right and so he says
Sena had no problem with grief and
falling tears as long as they remain
genuine or natural um we should seek
some kind of moderation in grief and
it's unnatural for extreme grief to be
prolonged for lengthy periods very good
right I think that's that's perfectly on
point
um he also talks about Sena and this is
quite right as well and I think this is
very important to point out Sena
himself is a here we go he is
um because stoicism is a philosophy and
not a religion it's based on arguments
not beliefs right senica as an
independent thinker was sometimes
critical of the earlier
stoics um for Sena being a philosopher
means a person is a critical thinker not
just a believer uh and he says while
very few people have noticed this did
extend stoic thought in significant ways
so you know this is I think this is on
point I don't know that very few people
have notice that but um it's certainly
something that doesn't get enough
attention perhaps and then finally
there's this great uh section on um
gratitude and love so he says another
stoic emotion that's been almost
entirely overlooked is the natural
feeling of gratitud ude senica wrote a
lengthy book on benefits which has been
called the first and for many centuries
the only great treaties on gratitude in
Western thought um so that that's quite
true as well and so bringing that up
strong point of this book I think and
gratitude is explored for you know pages
and pages in that chapter so a lot of
good stuff to say about this
work
no work tends to be completely perfect
and there's going to be a few things
that somebody might find problematic
about a book like this um probably the
things that I have to point out might be
viewed less as really damning criticisms
and more as quibbles asking for
something that perhaps an editor might
have taken out or something like this um
and some of them are you could say
surprises because I I know having had
conversations with him you know
something about what Fiddler himself
knows and I'm sometimes surprised that
it's not in the book so here they are um
the first is that there's a discussion
of friendship in here and you know
senica has a lot to say about friendship
um Aristotle gets mentioned and unpacked
quite a bit somebody who I'm kind of
surprised to not see brought up in this
because um senica himself talks about
him quite a bit he's not a contemporary
but several Generations prior to senica
who he uh Fiddler we'll talk about later
on Marcus tulus Cicero who wrote an
entire Dialogue on friendship taking
Aristotle's ideas going much further
with them in certain respects in in ways
that I think the stoics would be uh
influenced by so you know that's kind of
a a minor thing um I'm not convinced by
the argument that is given in there uh
which you know Fiddler is asserting the
historical Arc of eliminating slavery uh
originated from and was inspired by
stoicism I mean there is this notion of
natural law there is a lot of um you
know emphasis on our social nature
extending to all human
beings
um stoics did still you know live in a
time of
slavery um senica doesn't Advocate like
freeing all the slaves he says treat
your slaves as if they were like
employees or clients or something like
that um so I'm a little bit unconvinced
about that and then there's this you
know sort of genealogy going through
Thomas Jefferson and John Lock and yeah
I don't I don't really buy that part
myself but you can certainly say that
the stoics FED into that in certain
respects but I I don't know that we can
say there was that much Neo stoic or you
know contemporary modern stoic influence
in the founding fathers or other people
you know um when it comes to to
slavery um there's an assertion that
made that no Greek stoics participated
in politics I think on the whole that's
right but I don't think it's completely
right we know that Zen not that zenfon Z
Zeno was uh asked to go to the court of
the Macedonian King and instead of going
himself which would have been a certain
participation in politics right in a
monarchy he sends one of his students so
he's definitely interested kind of
helping out right and you know we see
that epicus himself okay he's not
engaging in politics but he has advice
for
people who are engaged in politics for
example you know calling out um one of
the local officials who got into a tiff
with the audience uh at a theater about
which actor to support and he's like you
need to be a good example so is is that
being involved in politics I guess
perhaps you know if you want to be very
rigorous about it no but it's not as if
they're not somehow involved in in
politics um the other thing that I find
a little bit dubious although it is
based on something is in the chapter on
love and
gratitude and
um Fiddler says we can all relate to
love as an emotion but the Roman
stressed a specific kind of love
Fostoria this term could be translated
as family love or human affection this
is the kind of love that stoics applied
to humanity as a whole which is also a
form of philanthropy or Love For All
Mankind Marcus aelius mentions this kind
of love repeatedly
um yes and no and philanthropy is often
philanthropia as a separate
um maybe synonymous emotion but in the
text it's not identical to
philia um and it's quite I mean senica
isn't talking about that because he's
writing in Latin so it's Amore or you
know other uh forms of of this term you
know AIO or things like that I I don't
know I think that's kind of pushing it a
little bit hard but that might seem
quibbling right so I don't really have
any big criticisms or complaints to make
about the work U that's the that's
that's the totality of my gripes and
quibbles so final thoughts I am grateful
to David fidd for sending me a copy of
this book when it came out and uh I read
it and and have reread it several times
since I got it I've been wanting to do
this review for quite a while I I
without any reservation recommend this
work as a nice companion piece to
senica's writings and if you want to get
somebody into thinking about stoicism
more broadly or about senica
specifically I think this would be a
great book for the ordinary interested
literate person
reader um it's written very very well uh
it's what I like about this book is as I
mentioned before fidd is not
overwhelming you with too much but he's
giving you lots and lots of if you want
to go further go check this out and
making a lot of correlations providing
lots of examples analogies metaphors so
uh overall great work check it out you
might be able to get it from your local
library or uh go out and purchase it and
it would make a great gift for other
people who you think could benefit from
reading
this